on american artifacts only on american
history tv
produced by the japanese committee for
the investigation of u.s war crimes in
vietnam testimony of truth was filmed
between december 1966 and january of
1967 and details civilian injuries and
deaths caused by u.s bombing in north
vietnam
the documentary debuted in may of 1967
at the bertrand russell international
war crimes tribunal in stockholm sweden
and comes to us courtesy of the
swarthmore college peace collection
it contains graphic scenes of war that
some viewers may find disturbing
on march the 16th 1965 in a street in
detroit michigan mrs ellis hers then 82
years old a nazi refugee and a
peace-loving quaker
turned herself into a blazing human
torch in protest of the united states
war in vietnam
in her final not accusing lyndon b
johnson before the creator of this world
she appealed as follows to the nations
of the world and the american people
awake and take action before it is too
late
yours is a responsibility to decide if
this world shall be a good place to live
for all human beings in dignity and
peace
or if it should blow itself up to
oblivion god is not marked
professor shingo shibata at jose
university tokyo who since 1952 had been
corresponding with her was one of those
to whom she addressed her final note
he was deeply moved by the depth of her
concern and her act of self-sacrifice
this led him to compile a collection of
her letters to him and the book was
published under the title phoenix
letters for peace
in japan the story of alice hearst and
the book were given a wide publicity
throughout japan
by the royalties on the book he founded
the peace fund in memory of mrs hurst
with a purpose to help the wall stricken
vietnamese people
and the ethnic victims of hiroshima and
nagasaki because if he felt this would
be the best way to correspond to the
wish of the late mrs hers
this film which was shown as a document
of the united states war crimes in
vietnam in the bertrand russell
international tribunal
held in stockholm from may the 2nd
through the 10th 1967
is presented as a gift by the alice
hearst peace fund to the people of other
countries including american people and
we hope
that this film will be helpful for your
work toward peace let us work ever
harder to fulfill the last wish of mrs
hearst so that there will be no war on
the earth but peace
the atrocities being committed by
america against the vietnamese people
have steadily grown worse
continuous air raids are now going on
against the democratic republic of
vietnam
at the beginning of 1966 bertrand
russell the british philosopher
proposed that an international war
crimes tribune will be organized in the
name of freedom and social justice and
based on international law
the war crimes committed in vietnam
should be judged by the conscience of
the world says earl russell
[Music]
in support of this appeal a japanese
committee for the investigation of war
crimes in vietnam was established in
october the same year
[Music]
last december
a team consisting of seven members was
sent to the democratic republic of
vietnam from japan
the team of investigators began their
examination of american war crimes in
vietnam walking by foot and seeing with
their own eyes
[Music]
we arrived in hanoi on december the 21st
two days before the christmas cease fire
mister farm got dark
chairman of the committee of the
democratic republic of vietnam for the
investigation of war crimes
and also minister of health and hygiene
colonel harvan low
vice chairman farm von buck he is also
chief justice of the supreme court
after making detailed arrangements on
objects methods and schedule of the
investigation
we started our on the spot survey
dividing the work between us
we started from hanoi to the south along
highway number one
by way of vin dong hoy and gutoy
our team first went down near to the
17th parallel
we then carried on our investigations in
tang ho
[Music]
and the city of hanoi
we drove more than two thousand miles
over twenty seven days
talked directly with more than two
hundred witnesses
and collected a great variety of
material evidence
bombing by the americans is mainly on
such non-military targets as densely
populated districts in villages and
cities
the city of vin the capital of the
gayang province
this is a place of total destruction not
even the features of this former
industrial center can be found
even the building of the international
control commission for supervision of
cessation of hostilities established on
the geneva agreements was bombed
[Music]
churches are no exception
[Music]
about 1 000 tons of bombs have been
dropped here in more than 63 air raids
this was the city of dong hoy the
capital of kuang bin province
this commercial town in central vietnam
which lies 40 miles from the 17th
parallel has been reduced to rubble
[Music]
their targets are only military
as you can see their aim is to destroy
our production and wipe us out
this was the city of donghui it has been
bombed
390 times continuing until today
it started when the air raids on the
north began on february the 7th 1965
hanoi the capital city of the democratic
republic of vietnam
this is how the residential district and
school buildings look now at the central
part of the city
[Music]
this gives the complete lie
to the united states administration's
claim that they refrain from bombing
non-military targets in hanoi
the facts are evident
[Music]
the city of haifang
this largest commercial city in the
delta of the songkoi river
has also been systematically destroyed
everywhere by raids with missiles and
rockets
the city of naam din
this was the center of the textile
industry it is now virtually in ruins
[Music]
only the monument on a street corner
shows that workers and their families
once were living here
many educational facilities have been
bombed by the united states
more than 120 schools have been
destroyed up till now
this is all that remains of the middle
school
in trident
one of the school boys says
air aids have destroyed all the school
buildings
we had sheltered in the dugout below the
passage but were all buried and narrowly
escaped death and crept out again
one woman teacher and 12 pupils across
the passage were killed
it was about nine o'clock in the morning
of july the 18th
an air raid began just as i came home
from school and i rushed out of the room
in a hurry
feeling uneasy about my father i was
running to the farm when down came a
bomb and i was knocked to the ground i
remember nothing else
because i felt unconscious
[Music]
she says
before the raids i used to come home
from school very happy with all my folks
father mother grandfather and
grandmother
but all 13 of them including an unborn
baby have been killed
only i am left
even little babies are innocent victims
of these american air raids
[Music]
america has systematically attacked
hospitals
in tying her and to the south in
particular they have bombed all
provincial and prefectural hospitals
this is the site of the former k-71
tuberculosis hospital in tangho province
there were some 50 buildings here
all are now destroyed
[Music]
thirty people including five doctors
were killed and many others wounded
[Music]
this donghoi hospital was the object of
an attack when the city of dong hoy was
first bombed in 1965
it has been bombed 13 times since then
raids have continued until now it has
ceased to function
[Music]
this nurse
miss huang tilly
injured by a bomb while she was
preparing for an operation
said
americans say that only military targets
are bombed
this is a downright lie
about a quarter past seven on the
morning of september the 11th 1965
there was the droning of a plane in the
southwest
bang went to bomb and i was knocked down
dizzy
what i will never forget is that the
doctor tried to continue his operation
although he himself had been
badly wounded
so that his innards
could almost be seen
mrs leon one of my fellow nurses had her
head split open and died
two children of hers are left orphans
americans have smashed our happy life
our indignation is beyond descriptions
who has lost one of his arms says
i was blown over by a bomb blast while
waiting for my brother for treatment
that day
coming to myself i found one of my arms
gone
and my brother had been killed there
the hospital building was clearly marked
with a large red cross
its destruction could not have been by
mistake
in carrying on their criminal war of
mass destruction
america is using supersonic jet planes
of the latest type
but above all they are using the most
criminal weapons of extermination
anti-personnel bombs forbidden by
international law
we collected and examined different
kinds of weapons in the bond areas
the chemicals used include yellow
phosphor poison gases herbicides and
defoliators
mr fan
tween
chairman of the committee for
investigation of war crimes of kwang bin
province showed that america is making
vietnam
a proving ground for their new weapons
in this kwangbin province including the
demilitarized zone on the 17th parallel
a machine gun ball
the fuse of an a palm bomb
a fuse from a cbu
the palm cinders scraped off the wall of
dong hoy hospital
as part of their strategy us planes
dropped transistor radios on both the
case and on its dry cells the name of
hitachi of japan can be read
forged money
pencils ballpoint pens and erasers were
dropped for the same purpose
tombow
ball ballpoint pen
made in japan
here we see a pineapple bomb
manufactured specifically for the
extermination of people
it weighs 20 pounds
when dropped its flanges open and it
explodes on touching the ground
on detonation
about 250 small steel pellets are
scattered and kill everything within 50
feet
this is the ball bomb
the canister bomb unit or cbu
it is the latest type
an improvement on the pineapple bomb
more effective for killing and maiming
it weighs about a pound
300 small steel pellets are in its shell
these kill over a range of 10 meters
the board explodes on landing
the parent bomb carrying these
holds the 300 to 600 small bombs
it separates into two pieces while
falling
and ball bombs scatter over a wide area
covering about six hundred feet
and three thousand feet in the direction
of flight
the ball bomb cannot destroy military
facilities
it is a weapon designed solely for the
purpose of mass murder
in the company of the international
investigation team sent by bertrand
russell
we listened to the victims of ball bombs
in the city of vignene
four children of mrs
vin t ray who stayed at home
were killed
an iron kettle and a vacuum bottle
riddled with steel pellets
this city of vinyen was the testing
ground for the mass use of these ball
bombs
the penetration of a steel pellet is
enough for a single shot to prove fatal
although the wound is small the pellet
causes complex injury inside the body
it can be found only by x-ray
it is impossible for mass-produced
victims to be treated quickly
this shows the back of a victim who
received
ball bomb wounds all over his body
here we see a patient undergoing
surgical treatment
the dark dots on these fingers are
caused by a cbu bomb
there is no doubt
that the ball bomb is a weapon of mass
destruction strictly forbidden by
international law
in the rural areas of binyan city
we were able to confirm the mass use of
ball bombs and their vast spread of
destruction
the white marks on the field show where
each of the ball bombs fell
here we see the countless shot holes
made by small steel pellets on the
farmhouse wall
the donghoy hospital was attacked 13
times with napalm bombs forbidden by
international law
we confirmed the use of napalm bombs by
the cinders on the wall of the hospital
and we brought some of these back with
us
now palm burns with terrific heat of
more than one thousand degrees
centigrade and the death rate from it is
very high
now the even more terrible supernatant
is being used
that is napalm mixed with yellow
phosphorus
the poison of yellow phosphorus
penetrates the skin
and causes deadly functional disorders
these keloid scars of napalm are no
different from those suffered by the
hiroshima victims of the united states
atom bomb
a victim of napalm in south vietnam
this man's arm not only has keloids but
is actually welded to his body
the mission of the national front for
liberation of south vietnam in hanoi
mr gwen van tien
head of the mission talks about the
present situation in south vietnam
american imperialists and their puppet
government are guilty of every kind of
war crime
such as
scorched earth operation chemical
warfare forced concentration of the
inhabitants into so-called strategic
hamlets experiments with new types of
death weapons and so on
here is the evidence
[Music]
she is a victim of american aggression
in the south and is now receiving
medical treatment in the north she says
when i was 18 i was arrested three times
and cruelly tortured for three years for
no other reason than that i was for a
united election as stipulated in the
geneva agreements
finally i was thrown out as a corpse in
the field
before i went to prison i weighed 256
pounds but when i was thrown out my
weight was only 122 pounds
it is now seven years since then but
both inside and outside of my body i am
covered with injuries
in prison there uh were some 240 people
only 14 of whom have survived
america has bombed dams dikes channels
and other irrigation facilities and is
trying to massacre the people by floods
and by destroying agriculture
they are doing saturation bombing of
dikes and irrigation facilities in the
delta zones where there is dense
population and good crops
even small canals and water controls
used for irrigation have been attacked
with rockets
there are no military facilities in the
neighborhood of dykes so destroyed
the fact that such raids are carried out
during the rainy season confirms the
real intentions of the american
imperialists
even farm houses standing here and there
in rice fields have not been excluded
from bombing attacks
in this house a family of parents and
the child were killed instantly by
sitting at table
[Music]
the school child of a farmer living in
the next house was also killed
[Music]
mrs chan the wei
at the same village tells about her four
children who were killed before her eyes
how sad i am
i was robbed of my husband without a
single word
my only child left also died
against the americans who have destroyed
this happiness
i will fight till there is not a single
american in vietnam
i hope you will make this cruelty of
america known to all the people of the
world
[Music]
in memory of her youngest child she
asked us to present it to japanese
mothers as a memento
this orphan boy named bong told us that
his mother
elder brother and younger sister were
all killed instantly and then he said
i want to study hard and train myself
and i will fight the americans to the
last
i hope japanese boys and girls will also
fight hand in hand with us vietnamese
my name don't get high
and back
um
this is gertruity
formerly a fishing village lying 13
miles from the 17th parallel
here americans first destroyed all the
houses with bombs and napalm
then cutting off the retreat of the
people they dropped a great number of
anti-personnel pineapple bombs
this was calculated mass murder
[Music]
in this way
three hamlets of good terry village were
completely wiped off the map
[Music]
we had an interview with an american
pilot held as a prisoner of war
lieutenant commander charles n tanner
from the aircraft carrier coral sea
which uses yokosuka japan as its base
what were the tactics you used in your
bombing attacks
other tactics
was
to
circle the town
uh with fragmentation bombs so as to
drive the people
into their air raid shelters in the
middle of the town
then as the people went into their
air raid shelters then
another pass was made
dropped napalm to burn them out of the
shelters
as they ran from the shelters out of the
town and then
cbu was dropped on the outskirts of town
to achieve total annihilation
could you distinguish between military
and non-military targets yes we studied
reconnaissance
in uh
[Music]
in most cases you can distinguish
what was your purpose yes
foodie was attacked for that purpose and
that aim
to demoralize the people
so they would put pressure upon their
government
to force a compromise to peacetime
president ho chi minh of the democratic
republic of vietnam
together with the international
investigation team we met president hull
severely condemning america for its war
crimes against the vietnamese people
premier fan von dong emphasized that
there cannot be peace in vietnam without
independence and unity for the people of
all vietnam
while in hanoi we held two press
interviews
deputy leader of the group mr ishijima
speaks
from what i have seen with my own eyes
and touched with my own hands i assert
on full responsibility of what the
united states administration says is a
lie
totally contrary
my impression and firm conviction is
that america is using the vietnamese
people as guinea pigs on whom they are
testing their new weapons
harrison salisbury of the new york times
wilfred burchett a famous australian
journalist
[Music]
the statement issued by the japanese
investigation team says
these acts by the united states clearly
constitute a crime of aggression against
the democratic republic of vietnam
a crime against peace and against
humanity the crime of the use of
unlawful and inhumane weapons poison
gases and chemical weapons which are
forbidden by international law
the crime of attack on non-military
targets and non-combatants and so on
[Music]
we earnestly hope that the results of
our investigations into these criminal
acts will make a contribution to ending
america's crimes and to winning a great
victory for vietnam and for independence
freedom and peace for the vietnamese
people
[Music]
you can watch archival films on public
affairs in their entirety on our weekly
series real america saturday at 10 pm
and sunday at 4 pm eastern here on
american history tv
sunday on book